how's it going rose my name is pewdiepie
welcome back
to the evil within as promised
we're gonna keep playing and i
am oh hello
um gary gary please don't make
don't do this gary please let me three
please lisa lisa you have to do
something
i don't want i don't i like my arms
i don't want you to eat them god damn it
they don't care gary never cares
just look at him he's full of nun [ __ ]
given
nice tie though gary
gary don't leave me i'm sorry lisa lisa
at least
god damn it well i guess i'll just
chill here for a while i suppose
i don't know look at my toes
oh oh okay
uh hi i didn't see you there buddy
that's the nice little friend you have
there on your face
oh god oh god don't make out with me
what it was a dream god
damn it it was getting so good
what the this game is so weird i love it
let's get grab some goo and
bodies found bodies found in lakeside's
town cause of death remains a mastery
more than a thousand mutilated oh sorry
dozen
that's a bit different found in village
of elk river
several residents accounted for well elk
river sounds like my kind of
what's going on the toilet exploded
anybody there oh god i'm not used to
this sensitivity on that i'm playing on
the ps4 by the way in case you're
curious
ps4 all the way
it's nice to actually see some next-gen
games coming out especially
whoa what are you doing
um yes is everyone else all right the
city
whatever are you talking about you are
the only soul here
right now i wonder what that sign means
i guess it'll follow her
i bet this is a double dream you know
how they always do in horror movies
oh
please sign in here
i need to sign what am i signing here
all right cool so you
save by signing in
awesome i like this
how does he have those weird smells i
love it smells like blood
oh nice little che very gothic
i would say hmm smells like medicine i
don't know why
am i supposed to stay all right please
relax
i am relaxed what are you talking about
please
have a seat okay
it has an icon of a brain i think i'm
not sure if i want to see it
hell he seems pretty comfortable oh [ __ ]
damn it ah not the brain hat
green gel can be used to upgrade
individual skill parameters stop
okay i don't have enough oh i have
enough okay cool
there now you see what an interesting
way
to upgrade your [ __ ]
what do you think i think this is
literally the definition
maybe because you look really hot today
maybe that's why
oh god
god damn it i just love japanese games
they have so much
charm in a different way i'll be wait oh
that ass they have that ass too
come on don't tell me you weren't
looking
okay i'm not i'm not like that
i'm not like that at all [ __ ]
what the hell is going on i mean what
the hell is going on
what is that what are we looking at
don't miss something
where are you a syringe
the original that looks pretty badass
so we crashed our amber lanes and we
stayed for quite a while
i think we need to find our characters
this is really [ __ ] cool i don't know
about you bros but i really like this
game so far
you don't it reminds me of siren blood
curse
which honestly is probably my favorite
horror game
in a long time not my all-time favorite
but
oh god
at least you try to tell an interesting
story which really hasn't been done in a
while
i haven't had a good start actually and
standing on a dead
moose now it's a cow always fun
who doesn't want to do that smack the
cow that's right stupid cow
just [ __ ] cow just showing your guts
to everyone
you disgust me stupid box oh
goo brain goo my favorite kind of gill
rain gill this episode was brought to
you by brain goo
the best kind of good that you can go
all over
just go to the crazy woman in your
dreams and upgrade your
goo abilities it'll be great
we promise he promised 100 results
this is where i'm supposed to be god
wait am i recording
yeah sorry is that my lantern because i
want it
thank you i remember this from the
oh god who's there
you better shape up cause i need a man
who can make me satisfied we better turn
off the lightning
should i use the syringe maybe yeah [ __ ]
it
all right let's sneak
yeah i remember the controls a little
bit that's a little cheating for me
hey man you want to share some of those
scooby snacks
i [ __ ] love scooby what is this
oh oh yeah
all the scooby snacks are mine now
oh god
oh my god oh my god
oh is that the nice ah ah why the [ __ ]
it invector
what are you doing back the [ __ ] up
connolly stand still kind of all right
let me just aim at your face
thank you uh that was i was trying to
[ __ ] off [ __ ] off connolly
can't really see any uh okay stance
don't question it
don't worry about it i'm sure we're fine
what a piece of [ __ ] gun is he still
after us
all right we're fine luckily connolly um
rain goo green goo
who are you hurts hurts
whoa emo
were you warning me about this you were
leslie right
i'm a police officer i'm maybe i should
help you
should help you [ __ ] is that a boy and a
girl leslie how am i gonna get you to a
hospital
hospital hospital hospital
what the [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
[ __ ] love japanese games even the
voice acting is
so good it's so good in a bad way kind
of i know it's not a japanese person but
still
not stupid i think
all right let's follow leslie it has to
be a girl but the
voice hold l one to sprain all right
cool
whip i like it i like this
like that like this this like that oh
it's a beautiful morning oh
beautiful morning indeed looks like
there's some ammo there approach a
fallen enemy and press
circle to burn them destroying them
completely
cool i love burning [ __ ] that sounded
wrong don't quote me on that
are these matches perhaps yes indeed
well i'll see you later
alligator hater
smells like bieber's new perfume not
that i would know how it smells like
you didn't hear anything
oh god i can smell edgar it gets fart
that's what it smells like
ah this looks this is like a nice little
place
i think i'll head in here please the
door with a lot of blood
blood on it that's yes that's where i
want to go
ah blood go blood goo
and the ponytail nurse went
inside the mirror while i look
constipated
oh well i can't move though blood goo
bloody blood goo and uh
police report finally got my goal badge
detected sebastian castellanos is that
us
i like the sound of that sounds long
seems a long time coming but they say
that i'm one of the fastest ever to rise
through the ranks
can't wait to get stated i know that i
can do more good as a detective than i
ever could as a cop
could as a beat cop plus i don't have to
wear that damn uniform anymore
they paid bump the pay bump doesn't hurt
either kcb
i can't read i'm sorry kcpd needs all
the help they can get
there's a seemingly dis disproportionate
amount of crime these days crimson city
is my home and it's my job to
protect it okay i'm really struggling to
read
oh [ __ ] it's like in school when you
have to read out loud
i i just that the pressures is too much
for me
even even now i'm like i swear to god
i'm not that
i love the touch of classic music too i
think it's
i'm back here now
so that means
we can save right i don't know if that
was a bad dream
or this we saved and then we can go
through the chair again
do we have to yeah i guess
so we level up through the chair
all right what should we upgrade our
weapons perhaps
i can't i need way more points for that
all right
well that was fun
okay so the mirror is
i really wish you could update our
stamina cause holy [ __ ]
we cannot run for long okay
so we can go back that's kind of cool i
like that
you just go through these mirrors that
is for some reason hung inside of
this really nice looking place
i don't know why i bother with a [ __ ]
gun
all right what do we got give me give me
your worst girl
oh god what's going on here
so one guy goes in to take a [ __ ] and
the other guy gets
he gets jealous so he slams the door
and he questions life while i sneak
control information
i feel like the main character kind of
looks like a spanish version of
uh the main guy from walking ah kill
what watch ah
no how did we [ __ ] that up how
no no no no he doesn't see me right
okay i think he lost track on me stupid
[ __ ]
he's either tired of running or he lost
track of me
i think number one
[ __ ] hell he was right [ __ ] there
too
he just turned around i thought i
thought he would close the door please
guess not is that lizzy
this is where i came from [ __ ] the guy
disappeared
perks of [ __ ] up okay here we go
we're fine bros we didn't take any
damage i'm i'm
i'm a pro all right play this game more
than you had
i'm just kidding you're beautiful all
right what have we got i wish i could
find more items
maybe some ammo or some [ __ ] thank you
gate for opening for me
much appreciated you are my favorite
gate
after they bill seems great
where we got here marcos
is that the guy nice toes
mary sheik hey are you guys from around
here
i don't know where
that firehouse lighthouse
what's up with it
okay this is some weird hentai [ __ ]
definitely some weird oh god
ah
oh damn no no no do they no they don't
see me
i have a bottle i remember bottles throw
they're like pokemons look stupid [ __ ]
all right we got two bottles
catch my poke ball [ __ ]
look how stupid they are
i shipped them so pretty
so that lighthouse is doing something
let's investigate this looks cool
so we're in this i feel like i'm being
pulled
just looking at it huh interesting
that's what he said it see i'm not being
sexist
he said it they both everyone said it
everyone just be like okay i'll shut up
i'm sorry
um
[ __ ] who put you there
what are you trying to do wagon wheel
what's your deal oh god
checkpoint sweet what does that even
mean
um island ipads
lens don't talk [ __ ] um
uh don't know what i'm doing here bruce
to be 100 honest with you which i always
am of course
is there anyone here like i don't see
anyone
seems like a lot of stuff is going on
though seems like there's a party
a porta pott party which is of course my
favorite kind of parties
disappearing where
where is it
to go back to home screen why would i go
back to home screen shout out
playstation
oh god no i didn't see you
oh god ah what def
oh god a trap let's see if we can learn
them in go
go go go go pokemon
that's how it's done pewdiepie town
oh god he's coming to check
uh oh
[ __ ] bruce
all right i want to kill him are there
more though i can't see it's so [ __ ]
dark because i have this
[ __ ] light on my face oh god no no
you see me
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
come here you little piece of [ __ ]
explode please
that's pretty nice thank you very much
all right let's go in we need to do oh
another tribe
oh [ __ ] all right we'll stealth kill
this guy
now are you [ __ ] kidding me don't
touch me
i'm swedish and beautiful and nice hello
why don't you come here babe
three hugs oh he said
that's oh cool i need that
syringe please heroin
oh i feel great now oh that was awesome
heroin when the feeling's gone and you
don't do heroin drugs what what do i
just say
don't do drugs bros unless it's video
games
anything is okay in video games not
anything obviously
like don't hurt dogs in games
that's [ __ ] up why would you do that
this just makes me question everything
about you really
am i lost no what are you talking about
i saw a guy with a torch
there he is i want his [ __ ] torch
because he can
use the torches to lit [ __ ] on fire
oh god
i'm gonna die let's hug his brains out
hey you wanna
brain hug it's free there you go
actually it's not three there we go give
me that torch [ __ ]
wait did you have something else oh
why thank you man appreciate it
ah that's a trap
ah i don't think i didn't see that man
another one i'm very good
and what about oh three almost step down
you crazy
who puts three bear traps
in one spot that's the dumbest thing
ever
okay what am i doing
i need to reload how do i reload
where did my torch go that is the real
quick there you are okay
it's still chilling down there that's
cool
they look pretty dead nice nice piercing
you got there man
who fought these guys though that's the
real question can i
can i what am i doing here this does not
look this is not
there we go oh god he is alive
okay okay um how do i yes
[ __ ] on f wow this stay away
stay away ah no
yes
oh that's awesome
that was pretty good i would say where
did they go though
where did the flame guy go you just burn
up
what do we got here x
got it
45 the best youtuber let's be honest
here come on
45 keeping the wheels and
i don't i don't got i i'm sorry i tried
they closed after me checkpoint
sweet brush we are doing so good
like i don't even know look at that
ace jiggle look at that spanish ace
look at that as you go it sings yes
everyone's
i don't trust anything i should probably
turn off my
there we go it's so dark though oh
what was that there's one there
should probably probably go this way
bruce
don't worry i know exactly what i'm
doing i never failed ever in a game ever
so you are in safe hands bros if you are
scared
good god um that's right
just keep doing what you're doing stupid
zambies
so what's your plan now gonzalez
i'm just gonna keep calling you good
journalist what what's the plan here
gonzalez
how are you gonna just distract him
there must be something right
come on give me a bottle or some [ __ ]
i should probably stealth kill him okay
let's hug his back face everyone has a
back face you don't know what that is
seriously
how did you make it this far in life
without a back face
how do you talk to people behind your
back then
i'm serious that's impressive
you should get a price all right here we
go
no [ __ ] you what happened what the [ __ ]
was that
did i kill someone else oh i think i
woke something that i shouldn't have
jab bloody fit on this bringer
beastbringer oh bobby springer this
springer or
springer [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] that was not part of the plan why
aren't they eating
son of a [ __ ] oh god what do i do
uh yes here god damn it
oh [ __ ] i [ __ ] up bruce
oh [ __ ] oh damn i couldn't do that why
didn't i do that before
a boat oh god
it's funny because he's fat oh [ __ ]
they're like well i'm not going near
that [ __ ]
let's go and get some nando's boys
and we did it chapter two
give me a high five that's pretty
awesome
i don't know about you bros but i can
appreciate this game
i hope your brothers are as well if you
enjoy watching go ahead and hit that
like
button bros i very much appreciate it
i'll try and do a chapter
each episode i might have to go back on
that
but it is a long game so i think it
makes sense
to have some closure in between each one
of them
um yeah let me know what you think
appreciate you
hitting that thumbs up and being a bro
and i'll see you in the next one
keep supporting these series bros and
i'll see you